the film is boxcar Bertha and the way it
came about is that my husband had made a
film called bloody mama with Shelley
Winters and Bobby De Niro and and he
made it for AIP and they wanted another
woman gangster and I love to do research
I just love to do research so Rogers he
was looking for a woman gangster and I
tried finding information about women
gangsters and other than the you know
the most notorious like Bonnie and Clyde
ma Parker I really couldn't find much
and I called a friend of mine who worked
in the DA's office and I said getting
interesting things on women gangsters
why can't I find anything and I was just
astonished that I just couldn't find
more I thought I'd just go to library
and got Alessa
and he said well until very recently
there was a stigma against putting
anything in the news about women or
children and crime because of the way
women were thought of which is you know
not so good but in this case it worked
to their advantage I guess they wouldn't
really get in the news unless the crime
was so notorious that it couldn't be
overlooked so I said thank you very much
I went back to the library and I found a
book called the - story of boxcar Bertha
as told to dr. ben el reitman and it was
a story about a woman who was a hobo in
the 30s and she you know had some
intellectual and artistic background
some death but basically she was just a
hobo and went from one place to the
other bite jumping on a boxcar when she
felt like it she had a lover who was an
IWW worker she actually end up ended up
doing social work in Chicago before
somehow she made her way to San
Francisco and when I tracked her down
that's where she was living as a
complete recluse and I thought that the
section of her story about
not being restricted by any of the kind
of things that we had just come out of
like white gloves and hats and so on was
a very interesting story to tell that it
was better I thought to come at the idea
of women's liberation and their their
position and why they were not treated
equally with men to come at it in this
kind of askew way so that's what I found
very interesting about the project so
the writer came in bill corrington he
was quite a character southern fellow
philosopher and he started working on
the project and then brought his wife in
to write with him joy Scranton and we
ended up in a story conference in which
bill says you know we should really
change the title of this to big bill
Shelley so that I could base it more on
my grandfather who was a 9ww worker well
showing my great maturity and how I
really in charge of everything I was I
burst into tears and left the room
so Roger came out and said what is the
matter and I said he wants to ruin it he
wants to make it the story of big bill
Shelley and set a boxcar birth and Roger
said well that's not going to happen and
I said well why not he's the writer and
he said because AIP wants a woman
gangster movie so if you start with
distribution you have certain pieces you
need to fill in so I was much relieved
by that and then Marty Scorsese came in
and this is where I got a real
eye-opening experience probably the most
I have been experienced of my life is as
a filmmaker and Marty had some idea
about the project also that had to do
with his relationship with his brother I
believe and once again I thought oh no
this is going to go all wrong my project
my story about this woman who lived
outside the system and then David
Carradine and Barbara Hershey came in
and
Roger thought that Barbara Hershey was a
little overweight and he told her agent
that she should drop a few pounds before
we started shooting not knowing that she
was pregnant with David's child so
Barbara and David now brought their own
dynamic to the project and I could see
right before my eyes that I had really
lost control I didn't know how much I'd
lost control until we got to Camden
Arkansas where the picture was to be
shot Marty had been there for a few
weeks before in pre-production and
preparing and we walked into his motel
room in Camden Arkansas walls was the
entire film sketched every single shot
of the pictures sketched by Marty and
there it was and we ended up with the
Marty Scorsese film boxcar Bertha and
how was that character perceived by the
audience oh by the audience well I'm not
sure about the audience but for me Marty
did so much more with my idea than I
ever could have done that I was just
astonished and thrilled and I mean to
this day I'm really in awe of Marty's
abilities as a filmmaker and he is the
total filmmaker and while I'm not a huge
fan of the possessory credit I think in
Marty's case there's no other way
you know he's seen more films than that
anybody so he comes at it from film
history he has memorized so many shots
of so many scenes and how they go
together and then he uses them and he
you know reuses them in cann
interconnected ways that you don't even
you're not even aware of it you're
looking at the film and then if it gets
dissected for you by by Marty or by you
know film critic who's very aware of all
of this you're just kind of astonished
again and of course as an editor even
though he had an editor he worked with
you know overtime Thelma
she was a mocker who was just you know
kind of amazing it was still Marty who
shot the picture it was still Marty
saying you know this is what I want to
do
and so I always thought that he was the
real force behind the editing of any of
its pictures and it didn't stop there I
mean anything that affected his picture
he was not happy to turn it over to
somebody else the music bhaskar Bertha
what was the music from the get-go he
was listening to Delta blues and he was
yeah did you ever keep in contact with
the real-life Bertha no she was very
reclusive she never would speak to me we
we tracked her down and we got her to
sign a release and paid some money to
her the public the Bennell reitman was
dead the publisher had gone out of
business there was tracking this woman
down was extremely difficult and I
actually did it through there's a kind
of hobo conventions there kind of you
know a little Sabrosa and read somebody
there who said yeah I know where she's
where she isn't so and do you know why
she was so reclusive because it sounds
like her life had been about total
freedom
and why would I know I was away I don't
know I was never able to find out
you